she's been dead maybe 10 minutes like
head chopped off no she died like
natural causes what I'd do it man she
was cute as hell on command oh sure
who's the boss poison her IV whoa
something's up guys we've been boiler
room
telamericorp was just a shell of a
company Alice probably felt some heat
from the feds right so she packed up in
the middle of the night that makes me
Vin Diesel who I'm Giovanni Ribisi oh
I'm like a Scott Caan Jamie Kennedy
combo doggie then Jamie Kennedy maybe I
feel that experience hello Dallas
okay let's talk what's the big to get in
on your game why aren't you here yet why
aren't we where yet oh Christ you're at
the old offices aren't you
we moved offices over the weekend it's
all I talked about for weeks
guys we moved offices oh yeah I forgot
yeah we just look hey Alice so we're
done with the old office right we're
never going back yeah never now get your
asses over here and get to work please
okay thanks Alice you sound like you're
looking good today
I get I had a Garth Brooks you kick it
he's talented Lou oh hey Alice how are
you what's up hey if you're still at the
office can you let the inspector in he's
locked out I don't want to piss him off
and knock at the $8,000 security deposit
back um no no no you must have
misunderstood us we are not at the whole
office we are watching the old office
the TV show on an iPad in the car on the
way to the new office
what hello
you